let's get more on that breaking gdp news
that we've had in the last half an hour
so the latest figures from the office
for national statistics shows that gdp
fell by an estimated 0.1
in quarter two that's april till june
and it's now estimated to be 0.6 above
its pre-coronavirus level gdp is
estimated to have fallen by 0.6
in june this year following an increase
of 0.4 percent in may 2022.
well milena vesselinovitch is at new
covent garden market in london for us
this morning so melania there's the
latest growth figures for the economy
amid projections that things are only
going to get worse so what's the feeling
there amongst businesses
well certainly the cost of living crisis
is starting to bite here as well this is
the uk's largest wholesale market it uh
produces and sells about 40 percent of
what ends up on plates in the capital it
normally uh sells wholesale goods to
places like restaurants hospitality as
well as specialist stores and what
they've said is seen is a change in
menus uh chefs moving away from very
expensive kind of protein items like
expensive beef and moving into more like
locally produced things that can be
transported cheaply we've spoken to one
wholesaler who said that this time of
year people normally want to buy
expensive french strawberries but
there's been no demand for that this
year also demand for asian expensive
fruit as well as mangoes that's also
come down on the other hand uh it's
flower retailers and wholesalers that
are really feeling the pinch as well
because that's possibly considered as a
luxury item and it's one of those things
that people and businesses start cutting
down on when the pinch gets tougher so
certainly the start of that cost of
living crisis and people having just
less disposable income is starting to be
felt here but wholesalers just moving in
and trying to adapt by trying to go a
bit more local